what's good y'all it's your boy corday
make sure y'all checking me out on the
bootleg cav podcast asap
boulet cav show special guest my guy
what's up long time super star court day
what up kevin how you feeling bro good
to see you man good to be here i was
just telling uh dwight the story about
the time i
uh me and head went to the kanye event
yeah we ran into you at the bus
a little bus where you had to catch a
bus in hollywood yep yep and you were by
yourself dolo and you had just moved out
to l.a probably a day or two before like
fresh i think we we you were you had
come on the show before that but
it was like you were like just like
enjoying the la [ __ ] like you know what
i'm saying yeah brand new it was the
kids see ghosts kids he goes yeah and we
took a bus there and like
yeah it was it was pretty crazy that was
a crazy ass night yeah it was a vibe it
was a vibe and i think i tweeted you
were signing the waiver and it said good
music on it yeah i took a picture of
yourself oh yeah yeah they signed the
good music that was a real thing that
was a real thing that was a real thing
people thought i was signing a good
musical yeah so what's up man how's
first of all congrats cause the album is
incredible thank you bro that means the
world to me appreciate that that's it
you know as dope as the first project
was i feel like you leveled up with this
one i feel like it feels more cohesive
it feels just more personal like thank
you bro thank you that means the world
appreciate that for real took your time
yeah i did you know i feel like you
could have followed up with a you know
within a year with that with the way the
last album went but yeah i feel like you
really took your time with this project
obviously you gave us like an ep gave us
some some taste but like what was for
you like was that on purpose to like
really not rush the sophomore album yeah
um now the string of things one you know
this pandemic right
i'm really a touring artist like i make
music to perform it
and um
two is like i always wanted to sort of
set myself up to where
i have a expectation
of taking my time without not an
expectation but it's just pacing myself
career-wise i'm career-wise excuse me i
know i could always deliver a high
quality album every two years you know
if i ought to drop the album in 2020
like back to back right out the lost boy
it wouldn't have been good you know in
my opinion it wouldn't have been at the
level to where i needed it to be and so
i just really i had to live a bunch of
life honestly to talk about some new
things you know um
and go through some [ __ ] in order to
express that into music
and um
yeah it wasn't a purpose it's funny
though the day that lost boy came out
i'm in my toe eight so i was like yeah
it's probably gonna be like another two
years before i drop another album like
[ __ ] what and i'm like all right you
gonna see but and but i it's not like
i'm just sitting there for six months
and then i'm like okay i got a year and
a half left let's get it done like i'm
working every day yeah the whole time
but
i just didn't want to rush it and just
put some [ __ ] out just to put some [ __ ]
out just to feed the algorithm you know
i just wanted
cause i know i would look back like 20
years from now 10 15 years from now
however long it may be and be like i'm
so glad that i took my time with this
album
versus i'll regret it more if i just
rushed and put out album versus now i
took this time out
all this time and creating and
cultivating this album
and putting all the energy all my effort
into it versus just throwing some [ __ ]
out rushing it out just to put it out
plus if we think of like the all-time
greats right we're thinking like
kendrick we think uh a lot of these guys
nahs like you know they took their time
from i mean these guys take their time
like for sure hole's not dropping every
12 months you know what i'm saying for
sure
yeah it's a couple is everybody got
their own path jj for a while he comes
every year every summer jay-z when i was
a kid
but you know yeah jay-z is the greatest
of all time for sure everybody got their
own path and it's not like i'm looking
at like a kendrick blueprint or like
okay kendrick dropped three years in
between his first and second now or two
years between his [ __ ] seven now so i
gotta it's just
what naturally how i progressed like i
recorded hundreds and hundreds of songs
but i knew
um what i wanted to say what point i
wanted to get across and i just wanted
to make a complete cohesive body of work
and i knew
um i just wanted to
take my time not with like actually
creating but with just finishing
everything up no i feel like over the
last couple years we've seen you in the
studio with
so many people yeah
um where it's like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's
in with oh man like um how much music
did not like you said you recorded
hundreds of songs like how tough was it
because 12 like obviously their songs
are already out yeah like when you put
when you when this album came out you
said press play from 1 to 12
consecutively yeah that's how i want you
to listen to the album for sure um
how
hard was it to keep it so tight because
you know you could have been 20 songs it
could have been you know for sure
not as hard as you think because every
song that's on the album as soon as i
recorded it i knew it made me feel a
certain way i was like
yeah i really like this one it was two
songs that i left off the album that i
really three songs that i really really
enjoyed i don't know if i'm going to
deluxe some or just wait and save them
for a whole new like body of work or a
whole new idea just put it out there
whatever but it was three songs that i
left out that i really like loved but at
one point in time every single song
that's on the album was like my favorite
song that i made at the time if that
makes sense that makes sense yeah and it
just they just happen to fit together um
it's dope that you have you put freddy
on the album because you guys also did
the record with nas for spotify
what's that first fight life is like it
was for spotify life is like a dice game
right um
i'm super happy you know what's crazy i
was really hoping you and benny would
have worked together i put you guys on a
text like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah i rock with bro to get you and
freddie uh you know to have him on the
record how how was that like how did you
guys relationship kind of grow from
maybe that life is like a dice game to
you know him hopping on that joint uh to
be honest like i don't like to say
things are more than what they are you
know what i'm saying freddie just it's
always just been a mutual respect as
fellow artists and peers and whenever we
see each other it's just love and
respect you know
um
and he seems like from you know my
interactions with him which haven't been
like too many but he seemed like a
stand-up guy you know what i'm saying
and
even more than that i just knew his
vocal tone on champagne glasses would
sound like really good and it did for
sure he did he delivered he definitely
delivered um
on the album you talk about
you got your pops uh pressure washer van
yeah yeah which which is dope by the way
so explain that so your your dad you you
set him up with a business you hooked
him up with a little small business like
tool yeah yeah he already had his
business like going you see the idea and
he didn't and you know he didn't like
call me and ask me anything it's just
something i wanted to sow a seed into
his business you know and but it's just
small things like that that's just
that makes me that makes what i do
worthwhile to me to where i'm able to
just like okay let me just sow a seed in
this business right here invest more
assault like invest into it you know and
um
it's a dope thing yeah i mean like i
feel like family's obviously very
important to you yeah it's been a big
theme of both your projects um on mama's
hood you talk about your boy who you
lost yeah for sure i was just on the
phone with it with his mom too literally
yesterday juwan ross i was on the phone
with his mom
and um
my bad i was just thinking out loud no
but i was just saying like um
that that was like a kind of a crazy
verse yeah i feel like there's so many
people who probably
have been in that position where they
got a friend who like
you know
they like you know did you like it felt
like you had some sort of guilt like
yeah for sure survival's guilt yeah i
think that's a real thing and i think a
lot of people go through that so to hear
you talk about it and like i don't i
don't think like people might have
expected that from you because i think
we look at you as kind of like
you know like um
not a street rapper yeah for sure like
to to know that one of your best friends
got into a shootout and passed away and
like how that made you feel was like you
know a pretty vulnerable moment on the
album was that something that like
happened and you knew right away i gotta
i gotta make sure i share this with the
world it's it was it kind of like
therapy no it wasn't more so i gotta
share it with the world um it just
happened
i wrote that song the week you know i
found out he got killed and uh this is
somebody i'm with every day in high
school we play basketball together um
even when i go to college he used to
always come up and visit me and
you know um
and all of these things so when he got
killed man i just felt like guilty like
man i could have saved them like i
single-handedly i felt like man i might
as well pull the trigger because i could
have just saved him you know and um
when that beat came on it just gave me
like those vibes and um i say that to
say that uh
it's unfortunate that it takes you know
like i said a lot of my music it it's a
real life experience just transmuted
into emotions and musical form and
unfortunately sometimes it's something
as tragic as that sparks a song you know
and um yeah it's a crazy thing man it's
an unfortunate part of life like i lost
a lot of people that i grew up with rest
in peace a little tony um rest in peace
fly brandon and one of my friends got
killed in middle school brandon um tony
got killed right after we graduated
juwan and it's just so many people i
grew up with you know that i'm with day
to day we live in the same neighborhood
this and that i'm like
be a day later i'm like damn we're just
walking home from school together they
getting killed you know and so it just
really been bugging me because it's
something that
i've gotten used to you know people that
i'm with every day and going to school
with
getting either killed prematurely before
they're 18 years old in some cases
um or getting locked up for a super long
time and it's something i've like grown
accustomed to used to to where like i
may not even shed a tear you know on and
it's not because i'm not empathetic or i
love them i'll miss them but because i'm
just so used to the [ __ ] and i'm
thinking it's normalized to me so i'm
thinking it's normal when i'm talking to
other people about it they like nah you
get desensitized yeah exactly um
i mean keeping it with your homies like
talk about how the intro and your boy
shiloh being part of the album how that
like like kind of give people the
background on who shiloh is and yeah you
know he's got the interlude and the
intro yeah yeah so shallow that's my
brother like um we we from
and we we're not blood but we always was
with each other since day one so we
always used to tell everybody was
brothers who was both like light skinned
or whatever so um this is like my
brother
and um
he was rapping as well like before i was
not before i was but at the same time
but he was popping before i was
and uh me seeing him like that close but
he was still like super heavy in the
street [ __ ] you know
and um
so me seeing him like glowing up in his
way just on some straight street buzz on
didn't have no manager then i was his
manager at one point in time you were a
man yeah yeah i was managing him because
i just knew like okay i know how to
upload [ __ ] to like a tune quarter i
know how to monetize it just the regular
basic [ __ ] yeah small [ __ ] and so um
me seeing him go up that kind of
a lot of times it just takes you seeing
things especially up close to
understand that you can attain the same
sort of things even to a higher level
and um
us growing up together um him getting
locked up for 25 24 years to be exact
for murder um that's something that that
messed up with me psychologically
because i end up blowing up um
or getting on the scene more so the year
after he gets locked up so i'm like damn
if i was able to if i was at where i'm
at now he might be in a whole different
situation you know
but um
that's why i thought it was very
important to to highlight where he's at
you know on the intro and in the loot as
well that's dope um i was just on the
phone with a matter of fact when i came
in here oh word yeah yeah yeah well
that's dope yeah so when he like yeah i
mean how how long is he gonna be this is
he got a while or yeah he got 24 years
[ __ ] but um we working right now i'm
working with a bunch of he got a team of
lawyers and i'm working with robert
rooks from reform and
um a couple other guys to to really put
all the resources that we have now and
able to in order to get him out as well
as my dog mac his co-defender who got 30
years another one of my dogs so
this is um just just trying to utilize
this access to
of relationships i have to be able to
help especially so close to home
do you um
with with what you know i feel like
a lot of people during the pandemic
during kind of what happened like in in
june of 2020 like yeah like
there was a lot of uh
i feel like there's a lot of fake
wokeness for sure a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
predatory um
you know people were doing a lot of
posting and a lot of [ __ ] just for to
make themselves feel good for sure it
was very trendy absolutely nah that's a
hundred percent all day um but
you obviously ended up getting arrested
i think my son was there yeah yeah was
trey there uh yeah yep trade the truth
yep absolutely
what is your take on that man because i
do feel like
we see it now right like there's hell of
[ __ ] that's still going on in the world
and but it's not as trendy
as it was because it's not as trendy for
sure you'll see like a lot of artists
like that like you were like oh or a lot
of people in the it for that matter like
what like like what is your thought on
that like you know because as somebody
who like really sacrificed their freedom
yeah to you know push against injustice
um
you know does it kind of make you feel a
certain type of way when you when you
kind of notice it's like there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on too you know at
first i did because again this is
something i've been doing since i was
like a a kid and you know i'm far from
an activist i don't have all the answers
i'm not perfect right um
but
i was going to you know philando castile
um protest as a kid mike brown and as a
teenager on my own free will
and um the only difference now is i
actually have a platform
and i actually got a felony from getting
arrested that day like i just got that
removed like off my i couldn't even like
travel overseas or anything because i
had a felony
yeah yeah i couldn't and so i just got
it removed thank god
and um
so i say all that to say at first i used
to get mad because i see a lot of people
just doing it because it's trendy and
you know but i was like you know
especially artists you know um what was
the term
that i used for it was um
i
i forgot the term i had for but i can't
remember off the top of the head
but um
i can't i forgot the term i can't
remember any who but um at first i used
to get real mad at like you know all the
fake actors activism the fake walkness
whatever especially from entertainers
and things that nature because i know
they're doing it for their own internal
benefits so that people can be like oh
yeah you're a real one you really but
then i thought about it even if they
intentions aren't pure and coming from a
real and pure place at least they are
getting the message out there the people
that need to see it bringing more eyes
to them
even if you know like even if you're the
biggest person on the planet and you
don't really believe in the cause and
you're just doing it from an impure
place well at least you're you're
showcasing
um the the problems that we got going on
in the world in general to your platform
to where people may be educated on it
want to do something about it so i don't
get mad at it honestly no more i used to
and
you know it's a james baldwin quote to
be black in america and just somewhat
um aware of what's going on is to be
enraged all the time
and
and i try to stay aware of everything
but
i try not to let everything get me super
enraged if that makes sense if
you really like if you really pay
attention to everything that you're
going to be mad all the time it's going
to penetrate your peace nah it is for
sure and it does like it's hard
especially
it's again survivors remorse as in even
you know with just my immediate circle
but just with the whole
community as a whole you know you want
to
do everything and give as much as you
can possibly to everybody but it may not
even be possible you know
um on the project you talk a bit about
like signing like young and you know i
feel like you're one of the more
smarter young artists we have as far as
um i feel like you're very self-aware
yeah you started your own label high
level which you got on your shirt right
there appreciate you i gotta get you
some gear as well yeah um
you know when you're a kid like you who
i mean when did you sign officially
18 17. i believe so like 19.
i'm i'm assuming that like
you know you probably have learned a lot
since then for sure the business maybe
about your own contract and i'm sure
like with your own label like what are
the things that you're applying to like
being a ceo having a label having an
imprint
that you've learned from your own path
to you know being on a major label as a
as a young unproven artist nah for sure
um just freedom creative freedom
obviously it goes without saying right
um
allowing artists to control their own
destiny you know um and given whatever
knowledge we may have
um or not that we may have that me and
the team have through our you know years
of experience to the to the industry
because like i'm not ever going to sit
here and pretend like i got all the
answers and i know everything but i will
give the information the knowledge that
i have and utilize even more than that
the resources the relationships the
rolodex that we've been able to build
through operating at the level we've
been operating that and used that to
build artists um we have our own team of
in-house creatives in-house
videographers photographers wow creative
directors management
um a in-house a rs just and everything
we want to utilize this to build you
know not just artists producers
creatives in any multi assets yeah do
you have a have you signed your first
artist yet uh no we haven't no no no are
you actively looking man i'm looking
like crazy like i can't wait to go on
the road for people to come up to me and
rap and pitch their stuff because i
don't want to it was a couple of artists
that i was like very close to signing
but i was kind of getting um
anxious if you would i just wanted to
sign somebody just to sign somebody but
it would be a disservice to them you
know breathe take your time yeah it's no
rush it's no rush the right person will
come to you yeah it always works out
that way it always works out that way
100 um you you're one of the few guys in
your uh
generation that's got two songs with
eminem yeah um
shout out to eminem killed the remix on
the album thank you
you killed his remix yeah by the way i'd
like to point out your manager is a
crazy person he tried to tell me eminem
is one of the biggest club artists of
all time club artists he said he said
club ace your man's burnt out he's right
in there yeah ace is burning excuse me
yeah that's burnt what clubs you be
going to yeah that's crazy that's not
wow shout out to eminem
you know yeah yeah he he does stadiums
yeah you know
and he's not listening to the club i say
they ought to say um well that acorn
record yes that one that i mean yeah for
sure yeah the nade dog shake that but
these are also like still getting played
now but like you know in like you know
bars and [ __ ] but yeah yeah for sure i
blown up the story nice little slide to
ace yeah no oh that's he burned but
eminem um
has obviously put his arm around you man
he's obviously a fan of what you're
doing like
how talk about your guys's relationship
and and has he given you any advice or
yeah um so right before um i did the
killer remix for him and we had like an
hour and a half conversation about just
life about music hip-hop all different
types of things
and um
you know just he's always been showing
me genuine love and support very early
on and you know he i appreciate all love
and public support i get because it's
not like
you know i'm signed to him you know so
he doesn't have to do that i don't ever
feel entitled for anybody to show me any
love so whatever genuine love and
support i get publicly from any from
fellow peers fellow artists uh
dj's such as yourself
and your platform as well whatever love
i get i really appreciate that and i say
that to say he was just showing me a lot
of love publicly
and um we had a dope conversation he was
just like man we just got to get some
work in whatever i send you something
and yeah we got to get something in i'm
like bet
and so we probably had that convo like
june 2020 wow and i didn't send him the
record for him to get on until like
february 2021
and because i was just like i was trying
to find a song for him but i was like yo
this is eminem bro it's been like 10
months since
like he told me he got me with a record
i'm like let me just [ __ ] get this
[ __ ] you know like
and not waste that opportunity
and so i knew parables was the one
automatically because this vocal tone
fit that's slim shady all that his vocal
tone fits that perfectly
and um yeah it's a dope thing honestly
were you intimidated um to get on that
remix like did you like like did you did
you write harder does that make sense
like nah nah honestly um
um
he oh you know what i did um i did my
first verse for killer remix right i
sent it over to him
m and i did it and it was more on some
like
three stacks e40 type of flow and then m
called he was like yo i wanted you to be
like a little more like
lyrical like on some rap rap [ __ ] on it
i'm like
all right cool like whatever so i re he
had me like redo my verse on some more
rap because at first i just wanted to
because you know that song is more like
a yeah no a rap rap record it's more of
like a vibe sort of thing and so that's
why i gave that he was like i want you
to you know like attack it you know so
i'm like all right cool let's try that
if eminem asks you to redo your verse
you redo your verse for sure a hundred
percent you're like
man if anybody you know on a song i
haven't i haven't ever been asked that
before but um if anybody asked me to
redo it because i asked people to redo
their verses all the time for my song
for my album not all the time but i will
in a heartbeat anyone on this album that
you said hey can you do something
different
no actually everybody was one and done
with this but i've done it before like
like okay i like this one because
i just always want to uh to paint the
best picture whenever you add an artist
to your song or you get added to another
artist's song they already got their
canvas it's like what color palette are
you going to add to this vice versa um
do you feel the burden of like being
like
the young like i feel like
when you came out and that slim shady
freestyle came out and yeah um i feel
like you were like a much needed breath
of fresh air in the uh
climate that was 2018 2019 what because
when was that was like 2019 2018 2018 so
i feel like you kind of like
infused like some fresh air that was
needed in a real in my opinion one of
the worst [ __ ] errors of music was
like 2017 2018 yeah for sure um
but do you feel the burden of being like
the chosen one the golden child if you
will because i feel like that is kind of
like
what i think a lot of people look at you
like that like you're
from a younger younger generation one of
the only people who are really pushing
like bars and pushing like you know i
think a lot of just
quality and real you know what i mean do
you feel that not really to be honest i
always just wanted to be
i just want to be me like honestly and
it's not like i appreciate whatever but
are you aware that people look at you
that way
i try not to think about it too much you
know because i don't want to go in the
studio with that approach like oh i got
to be the savior yes i got to save this
[ __ ] i got to keep this [ __ ] hip-hop
[ __ ] like nah that's not it i just go
in and create music i just want to make
good music man like at a high level and
i value good music and good songs over
just like trying to bar bar bar bar bar
rat rap rap you know we always go i love
this hip hop [ __ ] we always gonna get
the raps off but i'm just trying to make
good music and um
i say that to say i have my own
expectations i try not to live into
or fit into anybody else's expectations
because that's not what's going to make
me happy what's going to make me happy
is being the best person the best artist
that i can be
what was the bigger deal for you uh a
wayne feature or a m feature hmm because
they're both goats
for sure i don't know they both were
like huge for me at the time especially
when i did the wayne video like
a lot of times man my new word for this
year the past six months is just
gratitude just living in the moment more
and just infinite gratitude because
before it would just be like i do some
crazy dope [ __ ] and i'll be okay what's
next let's keep it going tunnel vision
anytime you get wrapped up in like
just the work that you don't even
realize what you're doing yeah i always
tell people sometimes you got to stop
and say man
if you talk to yourself five years ago
you'd be like what
the [ __ ] nah for sure it's a balance
because you can't take that and get
complacent and correct smell your own
high horse too much like man i'm the
[ __ ]
you know but you gotta appreciate it
absolutely and so um one of those
moments was i was at the uh the wayne
video shoot we were shooting sinister uh
shout out edgar shout out hit boyfriend
the video goat right now yeah yeah he's
been doing that joint shout out here boy
and um so i'm looking at the video
and i'm like oh wow like
that's wayne wayne that's wayne bruh
that's that was the biggest thing for me
this is weezy this is arguably you can
argue he's the best rapper
whatever like his
his that 08 run like carter three yeah
no ceilings i mean we can go on carter
two we can go on for days about this man
catalog his impact and influences he got
too many sons
yo stop at the interview got to tell you
about our good folks at odd socks man
listen go to odd socks official.com use
the promo code 20 off save 20 off some
of the craziest socks you know they got
the ninja turtle joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shots of spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
was there somebody who you wanted to get
on the album
that
maybe just the schedules didn't align or
you couldn't get it turned in on time
yeah that was really close to happening
um not really man everybody who i wanted
on the album is ended up on there you
know because as soon as i make us even
like chronicles as soon as i make a song
i'll be like because most of the time i
try not to put features because it's
like when it's features
you gotta if you want to shoot a video
you got to work around everybody's
schedule things of that multiple
features yeah exactly and so um
but every song that has a feature as
soon as i made that song i was like okay
i'm gonna get this person on it as soon
as i made today i'm like i'm getting
gunning on this joint and these just all
happen to be people i got genuine
relationships with so it's not like i'm
paying for any feature by the way it's
just straight swaps you know so all of
the features on the album you didn't
have to pay for it didn't have to pay a
dime for straight swap respect so it's
like hey i got you when you need a
feature yeah for sure it's love because
i feel like if it's just a money play
for somebody like i don't even charge
anybody for features bro you know what
i'm saying like if you're doing a
feature it's because you genuinely [ __ ]
with the artist yeah for sure
and um
so i say all that to say that and these
are people i'm actually like close with
and like have like genuine relationships
with for the most part
and so like gun as soon as i made today
i'm like gonna this is the one we made
that journey in australia as soon as i
made chronicles i don't know why i was
like i gotta get her and dirk on this
you know those are both people i'm cool
with like mad cool with
um every single song you know with
stevie wonder i ended up cooking with
him for like a week before i got him to
do harmonica yeah when you say you were
cooking with stevie wonder for a week
yeah that's crazy so you're in this like
i'm in the studio with him in person
hanging out with stevie hanging out
getting in the studio getting the real
gems the real knowledge they don't make
them like him anymore wow this is
michael his stories that he got about
like your icons icon you know wow like
it's just the most um unimaginable thing
man like for he talks about like
obama pulling up on him at the studio
like before he was president
you know like his story is just
different bro no he's talking about
little mike you know like yeah i
remember one time i was in there with
little i'm like bro what what was the
little mic story jesus it wasn't he just
brings up like small like things like
like he's michael jackson's big homie
that's so crazy you gotta think that
this is michael jackson's big homie and
now he's your big homie
good company virgo connection was he
like um just a fan of yours like like
that's a you know what's crazy because
i've seen stevie wonder pop out
before um i want to say at an anderson
pack show oh adult but he's out like you
i've seen stevie wonder three or four
times like at random [ __ ] and i'll just
be like
yeah he's living life bro he's living he
live a good life but he just was up on
like like how did that happen like so
somebody from his team reached out to um
somebody on my team to dallas i believe
shout out to dallas and they was like um
yo like stevie want to like lock in with
cordee and i was like what done deal
done so i pulled up on him and we just
started uh he had me work on the record
for his
and um
blase blas so we working on this uh
can't put in the hands of faith we're
working on his record and um like day
two or three he's like yo if you want me
um something on your album
then uh i got you and i'm like i had my
laptop and my hard drive with me like
say less i was like yo can i get you to
play harmonica on this because i like
using people's like almost
if you know stevie wonder you know him
playing harmonica isn't a hidden talent
right but to like the average just music
person they may not know him playing
harmonica
same with like j cole getting him to
produce on him to make a beat you know
like i like using people's hidden
talents and and and highlighting them
and so i say that to say um yeah just
locking in with him like it's crazy like
he just matter of fact he called me
today the album drop he facetimed me
and um yeah it's about i'm not even
trying i'm just speaking my truth that's
amazing speaking
it's an interesting way for stevie
wonder to call somebody it's facetime he
uses it pretty adept i didn't believe he
was blind when i first met him i feel
like when you he's been as blind as he's
been like i've as long as he's been for
yeah for sure he's definitely blind by
the way but
um he's like super it's not a crutch for
him it's just like it's like daredevil
kind of like you watching daredevil on
netflix you're like this guy is not
blind like yeah no he just said he's
been blindfolded he's 70 years old i
don't know when he went blind but he's
been blind for a long time it probably
also helps that he was once not blind
and he's a rich blind man rich blind
like super rich if you're going to be
blind you might you got to be rich blind
so it's like it's so much probably like
and mind you this is just like
me inferring me guessing it's probably
like so much technology he has like
access to to make him being blind like
super easy because he's just like filthy
rich you
know for real so shout out to stevie
wonder oh sure you i saw you allude that
you you have an unreleased juice world
song yeah i do yeah um you obviously i
remember when that tour happened yeah it
was like super early on super early on
now i feel like you didn't even i don't
even know if the ybn mixtape was out yet
no it wasn't it sure wasn't it was like
like all i had was three songs
short and two of them was damn freestyle
you know yeah and um out that whole set
was unreleased but man that was like
it's some real historical [ __ ] because
just looking just at my what i've done
or
just that's something i'm always gonna
be able to tell my kids like my my first
time ever touring was on i was throwing
with juice world and juice this is his
first tour too so this is both of our
first time kids first like tour being
that [ __ ] like he was no that
was his first tour ever yeah it happened
fast for him for sure yeah that was his
first tour ever was clever on that tour
no he wasn't clever it was me juice
world and little mosey wow and um
i'll just be looking back even at like
the marquis like juice world
chordae under it you know what i'm
saying and um
so i say that to say uh yeah we we do we
definitely got to unrelease that song
that you are interested in even
releasing or um in the future probably
you know i never wanted like when he
came out it wasn't like man i got to put
the funny enough man our last text
between each other was like about the
song you know
and um i i say all that to say that you
know when he passed it wasn't like it's
not something i want to capitalize on
and drop this record because i know it's
going to be it's going to go
yeah
yeah
one is a great song by the way two
um it's on some rap [ __ ] but i never
wanted to like
capitalize off a friend's death so if it
never comes out like
i'm cool with that he's rapping on it
yeah he's rapping like i'm trying to
tell people like juice world was like
one of the nicest mcs
ill like crazy like he chose to be like
a [ __ ] do the melody make super hits
like golly like not male
i remember when he came in freestyle for
me and head i was just like floored i
was like jesus christ like this guy's uh
you got to tell him to stop he's a
savant you got to tell him to stop
because you're just going to keep going
but like i said it's just something
that's more so like for my memories and
for the archives and you know
god willing if you know
um
obviously when when it comes to postmas
releasing music whenever um that time
comes so why did you say that that word
right because i don't know how to say it
every time i read it i don't know if i
said it correctly possible
yeah i don't know how to i honestly
might have mispronounced it who knows
yeah the comments will let us we'll
we'll find out later but yeah it's never
something i want to be like i'ma just
release this it might come out years
from now i might not ever come out you
know i'm just always it's something
that's just sacred to me more than
anything more than jonah just you know
capitalized off of friends you are a
part of like
a generation of artists where
your peers are dying are dying for sure
at like a rate that we've never seen in
hip hop is this more than like that 96
98 era right yeah for sure not even
close yeah it's not even close no for
sure like does that like you know i mean
i always tell likes i have some close
friends
that i you know i'll just be like yo you
got to chill because like i don't want
to wake up one day and like you're out
of town and you get shot or something
like yeah it's [ __ ] up
it's a wild time like and i feel like
you're like like i said like you're kind
of one of the bright lights
in our culture where it's like
you're not
promoting certain things you're not
you're not in into a lot of [ __ ]
you're not stirring up [ __ ] on the
internet you're not talking about
drug use [ __ ] like that but like
like is is it like what you know
these are your peers these are people
you know these are people who you've
seen at parties like yeah for sure it's
sad because nobody can relate to you
like other artists can we all are
our peers like you said we all appears
and co-workers in this ecosystem of
music
and so to see people that you're on like
um early shows where they've done early
tours whether you've seen them at
festivals or you know juice world
was the only one i was like really like
genuine close with right in a real real
way like really my like one of my
closest friends but just seeing you know
like the dolph situation that broke my
heart um
and how many others said i can't even
think of everybody at the top of my head
it's crazy it's crazy yeah it's like it
feels like once every like 60 days it's
like what the [ __ ] what is happening
it's it's it's a wild time man that's
ridiculous uh so there is gonna be a
deluxe
possibly possibly i don't know everyone
does the deluxe these days yeah yeah you
know what's funny i don't know i was
going to do a lost boy deluxe like way
way like when it first dropped before
everybody well i can't even say because
people been doing deluxes for 30
years but i think uzi kind of kicked off
this new deluxe yeah yeah yeah for sure
but definitely did 100
and um i don't know man i kind of just
like letting the idea in the project
just be an idea and what it is as a
complete body of work and just
going into something new but i'm not
sure honestly i don't know um you've had
a lot of big moments in your career
you've you've been on records with big
people you've performed at all the
awards i mean you've had some huge
moments what was the one moment that you
can reflect on that you felt either the
most nervous or where you really had to
like kind of pinch yourself like [ __ ]
this is actually about to happen or this
is happening you know what man it was
probably the day i got uh
um the best rap album grammy nomination
like that was in and i can't wait to win
them things in the future like you know
nominations are great infinite gratitude
but
i'm gonna win them things who are you
nominated alongside it was me tyler the
creator
oh igor yeah igor won it yep um which
wasn't a rap album i think he should
have won album of the year yes like you
know i'm not i wasn't owned but he was
what he said
after those awards is true like yeah
they should they kind of just bunched
them in with hip-hop i mean yeah for
sure it wasn't a rap album it was a
great album by the way amazing album
amazing now we should have won album of
the year like for sure and but i was
happy to see him win because he earned
it he's been in the game for a minute it
was his time you know
um
and i was just like well i just got to
pay my dues bro like he doesn't pay his
dues he doesn't put out great albums
that didn't get recognized so it was
just his time but i think he should have
won at the highest level which is our
mother yeah i agree and um
so yeah like um i say all that to say
probably getting nominated for best rap
album
at that i just remember that's the most
like i lived in the moment i was already
on vacation at the time i was in turks
and caicos wow and then i watched like
them announcing the grammy nominations
and
i remember because they said my name
last because they said in alphabetical
order so i heard the first four names
and then i ain't hear my name and it's
all because the ybn yeah exactly and so
by being i was like because i thought i
was like i thought i wasn't go because i
just knew i was gonna get it for sure i
knew i was gonna get it
and then when they said my name lad my
heart sung when i think my name didn't
get called and i heard it i'm like let's
[ __ ] go i didn't even care about the
best rap song right nomination i just
wanted that album album yeah cause
that's what mattered
bodies of work you want to be
you know people get best rap song and
nominations all the time but best rap
album that's a big deal no for sure
especially up against you know like a
tyler and things of that nature so i was
like
that that was probably the most like i
lived in the moment sort of moment for
me what were your expectations because
there's
your first week numbers are out right
yeah there's like narratives that you
know they might have underperformed how
do you feel about that whole
conversation man it's funny man because
like i don't um my bad [ __ ] oh i took
the label off anyway i don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah shout out to ralph's water all
right all right that's what you got me
drinking kevin what if i'm not [ __ ]
with you water's water baby no ph levels
in this buddy hey it's all good it's all
good i used to order like 7-eleven water
from postmates just from like just pure
laziness of not going anywho that's a
whole different story but um you know
with the first week things like
i'm at the
the point in my career to where i'm not
worried about no first week numbers and
i know it's [ __ ] oh well he's saying
that because of now i said this with my
last album i said it from the very
beginning you know like i'm not pressed
about no [ __ ] like that you know i'm
worried about what my tour is going to
do because i'm a touring artist you know
so
i make music to performance so when if
my tour is sold out off the album then i
know it's done what it's supposed to do
and um again i waited two and a half
years in between it without like any
touring and not this ain't no excuse or
anything i'm just saying like i make
music to tour so as long as my tours are
sold out
and my merch and people are like loving
the music that's what i care the most
about you know is it because like
there is a truth right to
uh artists these days in major
situations for the most part do you make
your my i mean
we're gonna get to how you made seven
million dollars okay allegedly allegedly
without dropping a [ __ ] song um but
no but like in general you know yg was
just talking about on um he was doing
the barbershop talk with lebron and he
was saying how he hasn't seen a cent off
any of his album sales this whole time
he's been on def jam yeah um so is it
like
is it indeed like you're touring your
merch your endorsement situation yeah
it's puma or coach yeah you're [ __ ]
everywhere you know thank you appreciate
it um
is that really where you're you're
getting your bread and butter
financially for sure like unless you
were like fully independent and you own
your masters like you're going to get
most of your majority of your bread from
uh you know the out other entities do
you own your masters nope no
not yet not yet
that's what i was kind of alluding to
earlier because you're you know when you
sign man yeah you sound young like you
signed early yeah for sure so i feel
like
you've already kind of
leveled up where you where you are
mentally and kind of understood how i
own a percentage of them but i don't you
owning your masses is like you own that
100 percent
100
so the next go round that's got to be in
the deal right yeah for sure
i gotta look i don't want to misquote
you know what my situation is or
anything but i gotta but it's on the way
all the way would you with the way the
industry is kind of moving and you're
seeing like a lot of artists have real
success independently would that be ever
a route that you would explore in the
future
i don't know honestly i really [ __ ] with
um atlantic records you know um
at this point in time right but um i
said i have to say i really [ __ ] with
them honestly like it's high level under
atlantic now that's a whole separate
entity so it's totally separate yeah
yeah like i got full control on my own
ship like creative control on everything
it's like they just do they just put it
out honestly you know
and they're enthusiastic about your [ __ ]
like yeah
like like i talked to everybody over
there everyone's always talking about
your [ __ ] yeah for sure and that's why i
signed with atlantic because that
enthusiasm and that excitement and
passion you know with julie greenwald
mike kaiser dallas so many other people
ray
um so many craig common all those um
people over there they were like you
know really enthusiastic and really
excited about everything
and um so i say all that to say that uh
i i like where i'm at honestly um
not even though no like politically
correct [ __ ] no it's like if it wasn't
i'll say it yeah 2022 album is out uh
[ __ ] you're doing coachella yeah
pandemic is still kind of going on yeah
we're still in the pandemic yeah no it's
wild yeah it's 100 we just like all
right it's just because the
economic reasons that we're not shut
down no for sure we should be shut down
if we were still shut down
it might be the end of america for sure
like finance for sure all the way
there'd be so many people killing
themselves and you're not it'd be done
i'd i'd be pissed off personally yeah i
feel like god damn i tore
oh no yeah it's crazy are you um are you
gonna tour the album yeah yeah i got i
tore in two weeks it starts in two weeks
starts in two weeks who's opening i'm
not sure yet honestly oh [ __ ] i mean for
two weeks away you might want to figure
that [ __ ] out absolutely i was hoping
for a high-level artist
honestly
exactly we got to find somebody yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah um yeah no
um i saw that namir was at at the
release party yeah um
appreciate you for djing that you and
zach beer that was a very random night
because i go to the party and ace comes
to me in a panic and he's like i need
you to dj and i was like
i don't have my laptop
he was like get it here and i was like
all right damn you must really [ __ ] with
ace that's my dog yeah i [ __ ] with ace
um
so i got a lot i had i got a laptop
delivered and
my the laptop that was delivered nico
blitz is was not compatible with
whatever [ __ ] dj it was a struggle
well i said i have to say the album
release party was an incredible event
thank you um shout out dave chappelle
you had dave chappelle do stand up yeah
um he hosted he jammed out yeah there
was a blunt circle backstage it was him
steve urkel
simba
somebody else was there oh
soda baby yeah it was the most random
blunt circle i've ever i was like yo
this is dave chappelle steve urkel hill
isn't it white yeah i can tell you guys
um later that night too man the same day
my album dropped um me and dave we went
to go pull up on kanye
and um yeah so after the album release
party you pulled up on kanye with dave
yeah yeah and um and a b actually abs a
b happened to be there that's my boy
shout out a.b
and um yeah i got the um this is my
first i met kanye before but it's the
first time i got to like chop it up with
him on some like you know
real conversation yeah exactly and like
you know that's one of my idols one of
my biggest fighter
for sure like i've said it a dozen times
and um he was like oh where are you i'm
just dropping he's like yeah play it for
me
and um
it was just dope man just to sit play my
album that just came out 30 minutes ago
with kanye and dave and just kick it
with him you know what i'm saying on
some some chill [ __ ] what what was did
he give you any feedback on the album or
just any any gems at all um i didn't ask
for it i just feel like kanye's just
when he talks it's like man he's
notables man he's the one yeah yeah he
played like some unreleased music ahead
like we're just playing track for track
you know like unreleased stuff
and man yay's the one bro i got
and i was a lot of times when i meet
like people i've idolized
i would not be too cool for school
but like you know cause i'm from
maryland bro we never we used to call it
like man you on dick like you dick
riding whatever whatever
and i never was the type like i meet
one of some of the biggest people you
can think of i never asked for a pick i
never like it just be just chopping up
on some human and human [ __ ]
but um
one of my biggest regrets was when i met
kobe i didn't get to tell him like what
he meant to me
like growing up how much of an idol he
was to me so when i met yay i just had
like in a real way i had to tell him
like man like
[ __ ] you my biggest influence i say
that i said when i'm in the interview
and they asked i say that he's like yeah
you better tell them [ __ ] like
i moved to l.a took a bus by myself with
two 30 year old strangers bulay kevin dj
had to come to your release party for
sure
did you get any free merch that night
remember we're trying to grab it yeah i
do yeah i did get it yeah good looks
yeah i definitely got it that fire merch
by the way hell yeah of course it's
gonna be fine how did the dave should
because obviously you and dave are from
the same region you know yeah
yeah from the dmv like um it's not uh he
sat on stage
that you called him to come and do this
yeah and he came he came and you know he
was like yo look everyone have have
their
nobody was allowed to have their phone
out everyone's phones was in bags except
mine yeah um wow and whoever else you
don't like that footage yeah um but uh
in general like it was a very like he
was doing it because he obviously
genuinely [ __ ] with you as a person as
an artist etc but how did that
relationship like what are the roots of
you and dave chappelle um we um where
did i first meet dave at
um i can't quite recall honestly
um when i first met him but um again we
both from the same area
um
whenever i first first met him like we
just we birthed both virgos excuse me
and um like he's one of my idols you
know what i'm saying i saw you when you
were on stage and the way you i feel
like you that was one of those moments
where you were like
[ __ ] dave chappelle's next to me on
my album release date yeah nah he's the
one bro dave chappelle is the one bro i
agree like not even like he's it's not
too many people that like unequivocally
who you can say they are the best at
what they've done and he's or what they
do he is actually the best at what he
does he's the greatest comedian of all
like alive yeah um you can argue of all
time i would say he's top three
yeah i think it's like him prior to
george carlin anyway but but he's the
greatest comedian alive correct right
and to me anyway in my opinion but maybe
i'm a little biased right but but even
before right
he's the greatest but um you know the
chappelle show even my sense of humor
man it's like super like dave chappelle
influenced
and um so we just continued to build i
would um even when i was making this
album i would go up to ohio to go see
him just because it's like in the middle
of nowhere i just get time to for peace
and quiet to think
on things
because he's got like a compound yeah
yeah he got he got a town he's got a
little he got a town yeah he has a town
in ohio did you go to any of those
comedy shows he was doing yeah i did
yeah i did i went to a couple actually
and um he's just always somebody to show
me love just been he's always a phone
call away man i'll just call him asking
for advice about
certain things and you know how to
maneuver and how does he do this and do
that you know like he's really like the
greatest man like pulling up on kanye
with dave chappelle is like crazy
[ __ ] quick dave is the one who
introduced us by the way i gotta make
sure i credit him on that because i just
think of like kanye being on the
chappelle show the double xl cover that
dave chappelle curated it was dead press
talib kwali
i think kanye was on there too
anyway do you remember that cover you
were probably a [ __ ] young child yeah
i don't remember that yeah yeah um
you're a big basketball guy how you
feeling about this year so far
because i know you're wizards i'm
wizards all day hey yeah addition by
subtraction yeah westbrook goes the
wizards are good yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah for sure yeah bradley beals
i don't know if you can correlate those
two but bradley bill is balling and
kuzma's balling yeah that boy kuzma is
nice yeah how did you ask something to
prove yeah yeah um you and kd got a cool
relationship right yeah yeah i would say
we cool i'm not like again i don't like
to exaggerate anything but that's like
that's the homie you know he we from the
same area he always
show love and support my music he's a
real [ __ ] who is your if you had to
give me like your top
five dmv rappers of all time excluding
corday who would they okay
top dmv rappers of all time yep
gotta go wale of course
gotta go shot glizzy okay gotta go fat
trail
free fat trail again free fat trail
again i did a record with him too when
he was out we got some [ __ ] together
um so boom boom cause those are just the
three that kicked in the door kicked
open the door for me wale
fat trail shot glizzy big flock and cute
a fool okay yeah and you got to put
logic in there as well
as far as just massiveness
big selling records selling out arenas
but those five are like the most
influential to you for sure but you
definitely got to put logic in there for
what he done and opened up the doors i'm
trying to think if there's anyone else
that i'm thinking from the dmv
that i used to really i mean
i mean you got a lot of them yeah that's
it shout out to the dmv man and then of
course court a now um yo so the album is
out you know rico nasties from the dmv
as well i did not know yeah on the whole
brent fires oh yeah brent's [ __ ]
brent fight and i was just going to find
all the time you know
brent fiers and rico nasty those are the
two people honestly that in that like
inspired me the most coming out of dmv
because we all not the same age but all
was coming up well they was up way
before i was they was already like but
they weren't superstars quite yet in
like 2017 2018 but they showed me
because i thought you had to be on some
street [ __ ] to blow up out of dmv
because that's what everybody was doing
like you know the cutie fools shabazz
big flock gunu
all of these cats shout out to all of
them i feel like brent's one of the more
underrated guys like when we just think
of like
how he came up how he was independent
just like now he's the ones business
model first of all the music is
incredible but high level everything
else that comes with like his story like
like how they were just operating just
so independent for so long as r b
singers like yeah we always think about
all these rappers that are independent
as [ __ ] shout out to russ shout out to
dolph shout out to all these independent
dudes yeah like brent feyers is
really independent as a [ __ ]
yeah on a whole nother level on some r b
[ __ ] yeah nah he's he's one of the ones
and seeing him and rico they both
was in their own their whole like own
lane you know not following like the dmv
trend both on their own lane doing it
executing at a high level so those two
[ __ ] right there was inspiring
the [ __ ] out of me what is uh on the
binge watch list for core day recent
like what are you binge watching at home
if you're at home chilling with the lady
what what are you guys throwing on i
don't really binge watch anything to be
honest bro i've been i'm even like the
day my album came out after i linked up
with yay and after the i'm release party
like i went straight back home and got
in the studio bro because you don't
watch tv
euphoria a little uh nah i don't i gotta
tap into that honestly like i'll like
watch um
i love the bms series i got to watch
that that [ __ ] was super fun shout out
lil meech shout out 50 cent that [ __ ]
was incredible you ever watch kirby
enthusiasm nope oh man it's the funniest
show ever i've i've heard that recently
from somebody else larry david he's this
old he's a guy who wrote seinfeld so
it's like a bro i just heard this from
somebody it's the funniest show like all
time i don't know who recommended me
this but somebody literally recommended
me kirby enthusiasm excuse me curb your
enthusiasm within the last two weeks you
gotta tap in yeah i must have to what
about um
your favorite movies ever give me three
movies that come to mind okay top chords
top movies ever
um now this
um pornography count
porn movies yeah sure
hmm i'm not [ __ ] with you what who's
this
we'll get to those who's your favorite
porn star ever of all time
oh okay you gotta go with the popeye's
chick just for the culture because like
that was just a moment in time the
popeyes you never seen the popeyes jump
[Music]
you recommended kirby enthusiasm
i recommend the popeye's jump
um
i don't know
like just top three
we'll do the porn stars first then the
movie sorry let's do the movie let's do
the movies let's do the movies all right
top three movies uh friday
this is just some ultimate just [ __ ]
[ __ ] to be honest but it's just my truth
is in my top three it's a great movie
changed my life great movie friday
um six years old talking like smokey
um
damn what's another movie i love i love
okay this is a random one because i just
got asked this question but in glorious
bastards oh so good i love that because
i'm a history [ __ ] fiend i love
history so whenever people incorporate
like history
into some [ __ ] i think that's the most
underappreciated quentin tarantino movie
great movie i was at the comedy store a
couple days ago and quentin tarantino
was sitting in the booth next to us by
himself
[ __ ] laughing his like the guy had
the loudest [ __ ] laugh in the whole
place but it was like it was kind of
surreal to be like oh [ __ ] i live in la
and sometimes you go to the comedy store
and you're sitting next to the greatest
director of all time yeah um one more
gloria's best is friday can it be tv
show or just strictly movies
give me a tv show [ __ ] it
i would say the chappelle show but if i
can't say the chappelle show i'll say
boondocks boondocks is amazing amazing
yeah
boondocks is up there okay porn stars
and then the interview's over okay porn
stars um i can't remember honestly it's
been such a minute because like i used
to love porn as a kid as a teenager but
it's like a vice
it's really bad for you no not it's like
i like after i finish i'll be like oh my
god what is wrong with me oh for sure
terrible human that is like the most
that every time you jerk off
and you know sometimes you you got
pornhub open and you end up with like 11
tabs yeah for sure you're gonna have
some credit cards to get scammed and
[ __ ] like and then you're like
damn what did i uh ah like what about
yeah for sure like yeah no it was what
did i just not the wave honestly i can
you never know what you're gonna get
right because you'll just start oh like
oh this is a cool tat like a cool
thumbnail
you're like
then you just you end up in a place that
you didn't know you were going to end up
in 30 minutes prior man
30 45
like
on a man it man i i really can't name
like the names off the top because it's
been a minute i'm not just trying to be
on some cool [ __ ] [ __ ] like oh you know
i don't want but um
i can't think of another one
not off the door
popeyes i forgot her name i can just
tell you like the scenario
it was it was shot it was a shot at a
puppy adam papa this is like this is
culture kev like at like this is this is
called how many years ago was this about
five four to five years ago
he's a creep you know what the popeyes
you know about the popeyes
right now bro i
advise you curb your enthusiasm popeye's
porno for sure just going to go on uh
eggs videos and type in popeyes and see
what pops maybe on pornhub i'm not sure
about x videos shout outs shout out to
the hub is life hub is life
well look um i appreciate you pulling up
man the album is dope i appreciate you
having me i was telling this to ace
i think i had that album maybe like a
week early you know
cohesively is
like perfect like you know i think on
the back like i feel like you know
i love the first album but i feel like
you know you you improved on the second
one nah thank you i appreciate that that
means the world to me hopefully we gotta
wait three years to get the next nah nah
nah i'm coming i'm
the world is back open it's like a
pandemic uh i'm coming you know every
artist has their uh
the area to where they just start
dropping [ __ ] and start going crazy i
think this is this is where i lied to
you on that how'd you make seven million
dollars this is the last question okay
um you know for all you know i could
have been lying man i mean you know it
was a nice flex how did you make you
know uh
less than seven million i mean how did
you get into lessons without putting out
music during a pandemic um
man just being more on honestly being
more mindful of my business more mindful
everything i do is a business expense
you know it's a write-off
um
investing in the real estate stocks and
bond this is just how you attain wealth
in general just in general more so
generalizing my turn not saying how i
made more or less right right right
yeah but like you're actually putting
money into yeah yeah in stocks bonds
real estate
um
i'm not too big on a crypto wave because
um
i would have to do a lot more research
on that but i i'm super like old school
more so with my safe stocks i found a
couple of gold mines like neo nio which
is like the chinese tesla
um
and i got into the stock market at a
great time this is when covey first
happened with that when it first
happened everything was super low no no
the dow jones on the 19 000. right now
it's at like 37 or something like that
so i dumped into it i was like i have
i'm in this blessed position to have
access to all this extra capital so i
just dumped in it you know doing certain
brand endorsement deals things of that
nature like yeah i mean what's your fly
[ __ ] well the latest one is coach right
no no i'm not a coach i'm puma all day
oh puma i feel like i feel like someone
told me you were [ __ ] with coach yeah
i was but you know how this [ __ ] that
[ __ ] didn't work out it's not then it
didn't work out but i'm puma all day
puma puma what is their biggest non-rap
check been so far don't daddy tell us
don't tell us how much just yeah where
was it from
puma puma all day [ __ ] pokemon man
they man i had to downgrade my lifestyle
when the pen didn't behave i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] we might have to start
[ __ ] doing uh swipe ups on the
stories and promos and [ __ ] for this is
like i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] how we finna do
this we ain't doing shows like [ __ ] now
but you know i didn't have to downgrade
my lifestyle at all that's dope are they
gonna give you your own sneaker soon yes
on the works right now yeah cause cold
sneakers fire yeah i feel like you're
you gotta get your sneaker man yeah nice
and it's already in the works it's gonna
be high level are you whatever you're
gonna be involved in the silhouette and
the design yeah yeah my boy uh ian
rutledge my boy ian michael excuse me uh
shout out to him has been helping on the
design
as well so uh it's gonna be uh
yeah yeah now puma and i've been with
puma like uh they've been rocking with
me earlier like i remember mellow before
a bunch and not saying you know whatever
but i remember a lot of these cats
they've been rocking with me
early early you know it was in the
location my locations video location
ships video was paid for by puma you
know so they i call them like my fairy
godmother man like because
they they just they treat me well over
there like no even like for my uh the
arm release they sent me like [ __ ]
ace of spades bottle and like man they
like they treat me really well like when
i'm doing things in conjunction with
puma they'll like fly me on like the
puma jet like i really [ __ ] with that
company man even more than that they're
like very and i'm not just saying this
because i'm getting a check for sure
this and that because with as an artist
it's a fine line you can't become like
too brand heavy because you lose like
you're you'll just look like you'll do
whatever for a dollar you know so i try
to remain like very reclusive when it
comes to brand alignment with anything
and anybody
and i think the less brand deals you
have is more cool because i could just
because of like who i am and the type of
the lane i mean i could [ __ ] be
cashing out you'll be on brands all the
daily features
but i yeah but i'll be slutting myself
out and in the long term if i'm just
taking every single brand deal every
year for sure and so i say that to say
that puma's been in alignment with what
i have for my vision and they're always
like helping with community projects
things that i'll never like have on
camera these are things that's just for
for my good karma and for to actually
help people they really like
into the community and things of that
nature so they got to do a puma
commercial with you lamello
and
the best puma athlete the starting
center for the best team in the nba
deandre
yeah saying shout out to the future oh
you are shout out cp3 that's my boy
yeah that's my dog he's a grown ass man
nah that's my boy like he'd be showing
me mad mad mad love and he's just like
reached out or no no we met um how did
me and cp3 meet
we met oh cause you know my family lives
in north carolina you know i was born in
in north carolina you know i was raised
a lot of maryland but i talked to
rhapsody about that she was like that
boy's from carolina yeah yeah yeah for
sure but but a lot i was i grew i was
born in raleigh north carolina like my
family lives in north carolina
and um so it's that carolina connection
and um yeah
he just shows like a lot of love man
gives a lot of insight and whatever like
he's one of the ones for real he's
probably the best point guard of like i
think he's your point guard top five all
time um yeah i mean like probably the
best leader in the nba over the last
like 20 years bro yeah every team he
goes to gets instantly better like play
off not even playing about the thunder
two years ago oh yes they thought they
were gonna tank yeah they were at five
seed in the west like no bro that is
like a a piece of advice cp3 has given
court a man just just lock in and and
and stay working like and just realize
what's your goal and just stay true to
yourself and you'd be [ __ ] pulling up
to these games you flew to phoenix to go
to the finals game yeah that the finals
yeah um i was late for it two hours i
know i was sitting like up above and i
saw you come in like yeah like end of
the government no no it was like five
minutes left in the fourth quarter i was
upset about it i know i had asim he's
like yo do you want to go to uh the
sun's game with corde and i was like
sure and then he was like yo he's gonna
be super [ __ ] late and i was like
well i'm i'm gonna just get my own
ticket yeah because i can't miss i mean
we ended up losing that game yeah i know
i was there for yeah i went there really
to support cp honestly you're at a lot
of games though you're like a real
[ __ ] basketball fan i appreciate that
and man you know i'm in a blessed
position but i've never been to an nba
game not courtside
really like i've never my first nba game
no no no i've never went to an nba game
as a kid so my first nba game was you
know me being a artist
um
so i've always been court side bro it's
it's a lesson you worked into the puma
deal
no no no no no no no no this is this is
this is how you splurge no i don't spend
no i don't spend no money on it it's
like either a player a lookout or like
somebody just randomly called like yo
you wanna go to you know what i'm saying
so like me having just relationships
with players they'd be like yo pull up
on the game bro i got you dude amazing
well shout out to my guy cordee i
appreciate you pulling up appreciate you
having me bro always love yes sir easy
money yeah boom